all right we have a special scene an
unseen addition impeachment style and
today Raymond Arroyo is with us Fox News
contributor and things that well should
have remained unseen Raymond what are
well the media really oversold this
hearing Laura breaking news tonight
bombshell testimony if the bombshell
news the bombshell from today the
bombshell the biggest bombshell was
supposedly that overheard conversation
between the president and ambassador
Soglin but to my eye the biggest
bombshell may have been how much witness
George Kent looked like Jimmy Olsen from
the old Superman movie oh yes I think he
looked a little bit more like Les
Nessman of this bespectacled Les Nessman
from WKRP grill remember he looked like
he drank a lot of water Lauder Laura
I mean fish are not this hydrated look
he's always taking [ __ ] look throughout
the hearing took slugs was he on the
treadmill with the water bottle do you
guys see this it's amazing it was like a
medical sized hit an oxygen chamber
water silo but the Democrats production
of the hearing was a big wanting
ambassador Taylor I'd like you to listen
to what he said
I'll read it for you it's in response
and he went on to read it when you're
playing a big dramatic moment make sure
the video is loaded and chairman Adam
Schiff had his own embarrassing moment
when Republican congresswoman Elise
Stefanik challenged the way he
embellished the president's call at the
first hearing mr. Chairman I ask
unanimous consent to enter into the
record the transcript from the July 25th
call between President Trump and
President zalenski you yourself mr.
chairman have mischaracterized the call
in fact in the first open hearing put it
in the rec priggish presentation does he
not well he it's very the Iser
oh no those cat I don't know but Laura
congresswoman Val Demings she had a
dramatic line of question I like the end
of the hearing and I think you could
call it any regular approach when you
realize that the interest of this
irregular channel highly irregular
informal channel of us policymaking can
I get it well none see Asian guide for
that it's it's they're speaking quickly
and they're thinking on their feet and
apparently congresswoman Jackie Speier
was so Feisal today Speier
she was so frazzled today she started
miss placing officer plies in her hair
if you look closely there's a paperclip
hanging for a man to go in for Haiti
that it's right there I there could be a
bike right there's a dossier under the
bangs laughs thinking that that small
Wells hiding a staple remover under his
never know what's under there another
Ukrainian source all in all it was such
an intense day for the day or it was
tense dramatic a pet therapy
organization called Pet Partners teamed
up with the pet industry joint Advisory
Council to provide therapy dogs that's
the capital that are you the various
members went and pet the therapy dogs to
de-stress
my question is where do the dogs go to
de-stress from this experience well why
don't we loose the therapy dogs on some
of these members of Congress I think I
could get a quorum for this all right
just say release the house release the
therapy hounds how we should start a new
house release the hounds those are the
cutest things we saw all day up there in
the Capitol well if Speer can protect
yourself with the that sounds like me
sometimes I forget like I forgot a
hairbrush to stick it out of the van
I'll stop Raymond thanks so much stay
tuned